MDV if I go for launch these no go for  launch  Abbey Misha director is no go for launch  t-minus 2 minutes 30 seconds and  counting come on hold it semester with a  hold for a loss of track come on count  abort happy clock stopped OS I'm ready  to say 50s greatest late 50s company BC  verify terminal count has aborted and at  terminal kind of board has started  thermocouple border started bees had  warning states trimmer County Board  warning space internal county board  BBC's barn fire anybody  oh it's not verify ready to say 50s  Airport samih where my ready sleep the  FPSO SMS rains make the empty essence  key property of ein LC ready for strong  back raise verify the cradle arms and  fully open and clear the rocket that's  ready our open D he's gone back race at  t-minus two minutes 26 seconds that  logic they don't have it the myth no  officer from the eastern range called a  hold because of a tracking issue and  with the instantaneous launch window  we are scrubbed for today